ferma mai possibile tornare solita state
oggi video epico che vede da un sacco di
tempo e cosa ha fatto un video del
genere e vi è piaciuto tantissimo quindi
secondo episodio va da unire tutti ai
dati positivi e bellissimi live ritiro
al di aver sempre però andiamo ad unirli
sapete dove nella piscina quindi vi
ricordate lo slime gigante nella piscina
che tra l'altro è tornato rosso da slay
messo per strada altre modenesi tutti
nella piscina vediamo quanto riusciamo a
riempire la piscina se magari straborda
non lo so sono troppo curiosa
mi raccomando lasciate un pensai che se
volete che unisca anche in islam
comprati quelli inclusi quadri dovuto
includere solo quelli fatti da neve
vitale però se volete che vista anche
quelli comprati da fare un bel laiche se
posso vivere nei 10000 d'alessandro
motiv e quelli del video potete scrivere
quale è stata uno stand che vi è
piaciuto più di così sta troppo nello
zaino mi piace più di tutti della mia
vi dirò lo stesso io ero stesso vitale
prendete i pop corn perché questo video
super efic lo mettetevi comodi figlio
tutto schermo e iniziamo subito negli
slam venendo qual è quello che mi
consentisse un salto che mi piacciono
però quello che mi ha colpito di più per
ora come allora questo è bellissimo
guardate un po se non sbaglio per sé
grassi che abbiamo fatto insieme con le
ricette del mio libro
tra l'altro il mio libro racconta
toseland non mi state scrivendo che vi
sto piace un sacco sono felicissimo lo
trovate nel link in descrizione sporte
compleanno anche noi sembra proprio la
classe con le stelle
a parte che è nero ma super lucido cioè
è troppo bello che ne pensi
quello mi piace tantissimo tu che regala
stesso prof stupendo mi dispiace
sacrificarlo
togliamo mario abbiamo beccati tutelate
un po che sfumatura vediamo o via giusto
per il più bella sotto con incredibile
ma qui ci sono un sacco di glitter che è
sfumato e un po viola per una galassia
viola che bello veramente una galassia
di glitter e stupendo questa bellissima
poté riflessi verdi però è stupendo che
vedete qua alcuni sono bellissimi e sono
fatta quest'estate in cui c'erano 40
gradi quindi alcuni probabilmente si
sono sciolti via grossi e iodio occhi
enormi nei dialoghi né bruttissimo cioè
così clothing propenso loro fatto io con
il bello la pallina la consistenza
bellissima però le cose dette fanno
schifo e poi e riposi mi piace tanto
anche questi qua mi piacciono tratta
tutti questi azzurrini ma soprattutto
questo qui di un altro super glossy
quale questo no questo torniamo a noi
no in realtà è un mezzo dunque a quelli
che non piacciono a te vitale doppia
allora fate morire
questo è gigante super morbido
anche se un po verde acqua è il
morbidissimo wow mescolamento dal quale
partiamo da quello più vicino questo
alimento qua
l'ho chiamato mostro verde in pratica
avete presente tutte le cose che mi
capita di vedere le sale giusti
sicuramente lo sapete benissimo ho
deciso di mischiare un po e metterli
tutti qua dentro curati questi diventate
è diventato un mostro mali che pesava
attendeva guardate il suo motore del
progetto verde scurissimo allora
edizioni no non tutte perché come potete
vedere sono tanti anni per la maggior
parte le varie edizioni del vero il
sacco ha detto a riversarlo allora
veniamo a giro ma tutto wow di gigante e
in serata morbido che strano prossima
audio di a pandev per strano spargere un
po è diventato fune grigio nel frattempo
grigio metallizzato o che abbiamo già
nostro primo strato di già riempito la
piscinetta praticamente mettiamo un
passo pacher a chi
che suoni vi aspettiamo che questo è
stata ecco fatto frosty paws lymon resto
non voglio immaginare come diventerà
contest live rigaste noi abbiamo un
[Musica]
bastava rimbalzando i quarti poi abbiamo
questo slime un po strano se ha una
stima sicuramente romancia ladies perché
dentro ci sono anche dei pon pon
oggi lo iodio compongono lo slime sotto
i sassi con glitter e palline stracci
eccolo qua
anche questo è bellissimo siamo qua nel
nostro bene
dopo mettere prima queste vengono
sepolti perché questo episodio veramente
sistema anche bernie dentro due brutti
si è indurito questo sembra gelatina fa
vedere che cosa c'è dentro gruppo ragni
era notorio mi dispiace perché parla
troppo schifo se non rovinano tutto
drive l'hanno fatta po impressione
vederli mai detto pozzi no il timo
questo questo è staccato da solo era
nota scrissi va bene togliamo riuscivo
fuori il cervello che andiamo a mettere
la società in dialoghi dopo spero di no
controlliamo
sicuramente ci sono idee o quasi alla
assistenza molto più e super grossi
e morbido guardatelo c'è un verme questo
cos'è pon pon
i due occhi
no mi sembra che non ci sono grandi
stranamente micolano che li avevamo
visti anche qua via questo si chiamano
chiamerà bene perché più appiccicoso
ma c'è una di noi ma ci sono un sacco di
glitter palloni nella schiena treno che
è diventata qualcosa non va
questo ok sta iniziando già 20 è sempre
la principessa devo dire che i colori
sono molto vari adesso allora che cosa
continuiamo ha sopra con tantissime
palline che questo li buttiamo ora un
bellissimo colore rotta prix click e la
ciliegia conoscimento ancora tutti i
clippers erano depositati qua sotto
c'erano i compiti si è sciolto un po
perché benissimo anche questo
allestimento così magari cambia colore
macchinetta trolio sotto del tutto io e
fate bravissimo a frey quindi un futuro
sì questo è proprio cliente durissimo
dove lo mettiamo
poi campo quest'anno veramente loro e se
no la fine del quale sono scelti visiva
che bello questo era con lo snow siemens
non mezzo qualcos'altro bagnetto
affrettata praticamente la frittata
celeste questa invece un
non ho questo morbidissimo bellissimo
questa superficie che bello mi dispiace
mi dispiace di sacrificarlo
ma lo faccio per voi ecosistemi allora
[Musica]
zucchero filato sì è vero che strano
petrovics di colori adesso poi mettiamo
passione così di crema pasticcera con
olio credibile una bella zuppa di sliven
allora prossimo questa mi sembra molto
interessante crediti con le palline che
trovato io a si no migone
credo di sì
che bello se mi sono rifatto male l'ho
fatto io ecco qua anche che sottrae
morosa mezzo
addio di questo show di questi sono
state super sciolto che cos'è una zuppa
pubblica strane di sliven a tantissimi
glitter consigliere storia mi dispiace
i glitter tantissimi un tocco di colore
un tocco di glitter a questo slime molto
bellino tutto bellissimo colore sono
troppo dicendo quando la quando rilanci
rimbalzo troviamo la mente tantissime
palline da un altro perde cadono tutte
le palline e fiona color lilla chiaro
che bene anche le conti niente sotto
questa era sotto il morbido questo
porterà più recentemente prossimo
abbiamo pantone dispiace un sacco perché
bellissimo non ce li chi un po viola con
i brillantini
a me non piace a gennaio perché no
perché io a fastidio con la spugnetta
questo era vecchissimo e sera sotto più
bello più uno sla sia limone adesso non
sarebbe uno zaino gigante mettiamo un po
come primo compito
il colore bellissimo post un uomo un blu
intenso bellissimo riscoprendo questo ai
bambini slang glitterato ha preso la
forma della scatoletta che questo
obiettivo venga perdere con tantissime
palline mai preso
[Musica]
senti che si era fatta una superficie
super dura speriamo non vuole andare a
mirti a niente live o mio dio fisica
adesso questo era il triplo
allora cosa sarebbe bello tantissimo e
si cade a strabordando colore verde per
me no
e più perde acqua cestino wow
questo è una merda celeste
l'imbarcazione figlio e tipo il mio
preferito etro
ufficio il rilassante bellissimo mi
spiace tanto di addio questo rischio è
un falso
il mio preferito si è mosso davvero
molto molto bello che anche la
consistenza e fantastico
mi dispiace sacra di addio ma ci sono
dei glitter dentro forse c'è un po di
neve questo lo avevamo fatto con la
challenge quella nel secchio cento
strati di slide è stato fantastico
bellissimo veramente mi dispiace troppo
direbbe addio ma tiri faremo ancora
meglio ma abbiamo ha colore ancora più
bello pronti addio pesa tantissimo non
farti male non vuole uscire non vuole
andare a cerano di glitter tipo un
incredibile presenta così spalle crisarà
di smith rosa si primo cross di verde
acqua bello che bello e super grossi
bellissimo andiamo anche questa lettera
mettiamoli poi questo slime è una sorta
di color pesca on air a severo pesca che
strano è fatto con la quale trasparente
dove lo più chi sa molto non tutto è
quasi un'altra striscia di colore si
ricorda questo scusare ma questo è lo
slime comandato da google della bella e
nabil india bellissimo infatti ed ora 8
con i glitter dorati e io questo è un
mischiato con un altro un lo ricordo
crif hickman t d oro l'avevo mischiato
con 1 oro che si era sciolto per un
matto
ci sono i vari strati di affido ai mille
strati e corretto allora prossimo questo
non è un fatto mail che lo so perché qui
con il club con durissimi ecco quali
matisse e pure duro non so se riusciremo
mischiamo bene questo magari si
allungano un po si erano strappano in
questo colore la vita fa la pizza della
ragazzina
mettiamo ci troviamo un altro slam
celestino non mi dire che anche questo
era affatto un amico lento un pochino
viola grigio grigio e tv lilla che ha
fatto ha scoraggiato questo tema
puzzolente a questi mitilini carini
[Risate]
viola però glitterato a glitter bione
dorati ma si è sciolto un pochino quindi
forse anche questo ero vecchio non lo so
forse non lo abbiamo attivato abbastanza
[Musica]
uno smile cremoso petto grafica
pochissimo qualche pochissimo alla fine
nodo metterli prima che ti permette di
mettersi meta la maledizione abbiamo un
bellissimo slide verde
tra l'altro questo record ed è brutto
messaggio è brutto stiamo lì queste due
sedute cardellino carino da in verde
menta carino
mi ha lanciato di da solo slime latte
mente questo verde qua invece è
bruttissimo a casa in gazzetta d'alba e
verde verde patrimonio verde pelle
grigio metallizzato però ma forse questo
non è vero ma in grigio metallizzato a
calcola 2 6 8 12
un altro slide per te cittadini non
ricopriamo l'angolo degli slam verdetti
nei casinò live the year book bello
pulito ben affrontato di questo
bellissimo mi dispiace un sacco perché è
un cerchio giallo con i clic rosa è
bellissimo but abu dhabi viaggio intimo
slime un lime rock gol bello e su
partita quando alla fine bertè che se
non sbaglio può essere affatto come un
po di clay lo stesso anno è molto carino
c'è un sacco di palline tantissime
siamo qua cosi coprirvi prossimo slang
slide viola con uno stacco di palline
rosa tutto a coprire il verbo ye line
molto particolare perché guardate e tv
napoli multicolor
guardate un po bellissimo c'è l'effetto
è stupendo wow mix di colori inter che
bello super davvero 3gg cube weber sono
tre quello bellissimo galassi book per
questo mi dispiace ma ho veramente una
galassia questo dove lo stupendo
tra l'altro lo slang preferito di vitale
quindi dei miti dispiaciuta cova www più
lento ma guardate che bello oltre ad
essere super lucido nel mio libro
provate la ricetta è bellissimo non
vogliono buttare mi dispiace sacrificare
che ci fa omosessuali nel motivo di
profonda passo meglio quindi gli altri
slime ne mancano solo due questo che ha
un colore che lo stupendo proprio viola
scuro e bellissimo
oltre ad essere super crosses questo se
non sbaglio lo avevi fatto tu in una
chat dance
sì forse che cosa sia quilici bello più
abbiamo questo slime stupendo che quello
con un sacco di sfumature una sorta di
galaxy di giorno timcal al 16
un galassi diurno
mi dispiace un sacco anche per questo
perché wow è incredibile quante glitter
osè questo è l'ultimo slime lo mettiamo
al centro
[Musica]
ok ragazzi ecco qua dovuti è enorme
pesantissimo veramente l'usl anche
gigante che abbia mai fatto e ci sono un
sacco di colori incredibile ora proviamo
ad andare a fischiarlo tutto allora
tigrotto poi tetti a tutto colore di
corato baleno adesso incredibile di
borgomanero è un po complicato da
mischiare vita restyling riguarda gli
sto rilassando
mi stanno sentendo questi suoni si sta
addormentando vista è onesto tempo per
lui
sembra un quadro adesso contenti i
colori basta certo vuol dire che questo
effetto punti come non mi piace è
bellissimo e un rainbows la gigantesca
allora ragazzi non mischiato che non sa
come faticosissimo fischierebbe su flier
perché gigantesco mi fanno male le
braccia adesso e quindi ho deciso per
ora di lasciarlo così alla fine a me
piace tantissimo questo risultato perché
è un re con praticamente è fighissimo di
sfumature la bozza porte e celeste e blu
poi però abbiamo sfumature del verde qua
a rosa è bellissimo c'è anche il dorato
per come ti ho un range tra il gigante
quindi l'interesse volete che continuerà
mischiano anche se secondo me è bello
così potevo sapere nei commenti
e ora vi lascio qua 4 caselline
supplicare per vedere i miei altri mille
se volete vedere le sale di capitali e
altri tra il video divertenti nuovi
video peter su quella che preferite e
buona visione